هنا ابناء عبد المجيد تبون لا يلعبون
الميزانيه العسكريه تتضاعف الى ثلاثه
اضعافها والدليفري الروسي لا يتوقف عن مد
الجزائر بالاسلحه وفي الضفه الاخرى الدول
العربيه تتودد للجزائر والهدف رائحه الغاز
الكل يبحث عن الطاقه تحضيرا لحرب لا تنطفئ
نارها ولا ينقطع دخانها ولكن مهلا بل ان
الجزائر قد تعلن عن نفسها كطرف في الحرب
لاشعال حفله الانتقام والتي لا زالت تشتعل
في صدور الجزائريين الى هذه اللحظه والهدف
اخذ الثار لاكثر من مليون ونصف المليون
شهيد سقط ضحايا الاحتلال الفرنسي وفرنسا
احد الاطراف الاساسيه للكافه الغربيه هناك
يسيل لعاب الجزائر وشعبها لاخذ انتقامهم
فالفرصه بواتيه والانتقام طعام يطبخ على
نار هادئه ويتذوق حلاوته اكثر من يتركه
ليبرد اكثر